shirt. Awesome. Oh, thank you. Noel.
Yeah. Lird.
[Music]
[Applause]
Free
bird. Shaking. It's cold.
[Music]
You don't even have to cut
off. Yes. Nice.
Boo. Boo.
You gave it away.
fun of
everything
that
keep
[Music]
man stuff really cool effects.
Sound effects. Sound effects.
[Music]
Yeah.
[Applause]
Get it. All right.
Nice. Nice. Like it. Hell yeah.
Do it again. Do it again.
Yeah.
One more. One more. Build it up. Build
it up. One time
like that.
[Applause]
you've ever seen before.
Oh my god,
[Applause]
this guy's an innovator.
something. This is in response to the
tech blog.
Yeah.
I know this one. It's my new one. Yeah,
we like
it. All
right.
Yeah.
[Applause]
Unicorn. Unicorn. Unicorn. First, I must
channel my
[Music]
I get your
alien to satisfy the unicorn.
Spell casting mana pool.
Narwhal. Narwhal. Thank you. I need the
narwhal. That's on you.
[Applause]
Thanks, Tiffany.
Very little fire. Anything left? Is
there anything left in here? Is there
anything left?
Platypus.
Dolphin. Dolphin.
Okay.
[Applause]
Tradition T-Rex.
[Laughter]
sort of insecurity.
My arms are kind of short. What are you
a vegetarian? Vegetarian.
Oh, vegetarian.
You would need that. You would need
fire.
[Applause]